Developed to help protect artwork from the
damages of dust and inspired by gecko feet,
researchers from Yale developed a non-sticky
plastic sheet that produces enough electrostatic
charge to remove dust from a surface by attaching
it to Micropillar structures.
And an arachnid preserved in iron carbonate
for 305 million years was recently analyzed
using computed tomography and it turns out
it’s a previously unknown creature that’s
a lot like a spider.
Vsauce!
Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
The way your brain thinks could be your new
password.
Researchers at Binghamton University have
developed a new brain biometric that uses
the brain’s response to a series of images.
To identify you with 100 percent accuracy.
So while wearing an EEG system, a specific
change in voltage at the scalp is recorded
reacting to images of certain celebrities
or uncommon words and then used as a passcode.
And the images can be changed - which unlike
your fingerprints or retinas - allows you
to change your brain password.
The major challenge is translating system
this to a consumer product.
One of the most advanced wind tunnels in the
world is being used to learn the flight secrets
of birds.
Drones currently have a hard time stabilizing
in turbulent conditions - so the new wind
tunnel allows researchers from Stanford University
to analyze how birds react to different turbulence
patterns.
Bearing in mind the safety of the birds - they
don’t crank up the speed to uncomfortable
levels.
And in the future, more advanced aerial robot
designs will undergo testing in this wind
tunnel.
The Stanford Robotics Lab has created a robotic
mermaid for exploring the ocean.
OceanOne is an underwater humanoid with stereoscopic
vision and force sensors on its hands that
provide haptic feedback to the pilot - giving
the human a feel for the objects.
Providing a physical avatar for humans to
dive and study areas of the ocean too dangerous
for people.
It’s already been used to explore the wreck
of King Louis XIV’s flagship, previously
out of reach for humans, and has recovered
artifacts.
AiCure hopes to monitor, track and make sure
patients are taking their medication.
They claim half of all patients don’t take
medication as prescribed - so this app visually
confirms the proper medication, confirms the
proper user ingests it and does so at the
proper time.
It’s customizable and adapts to patient
behavior.
The data can be accessed by medical providers
and can recognize improper or suspicious use.
And they hope this can reduce the reported
$198 billion dollars spent on hospitalizations
resulting from improper medication use each
year.
Researchers at the University of California,
Berkeley have charted subregions of the brain
that respond to different words.
The “semantic system” map displays the
organization of words based on meanings like
people, time, number, tactile, outdoor or
place.
This single brain combines and visualizes
six different people’s word meaning brain
activity.
Hopefully they can study more subjects from
different cultural upbringing and education
to see how consistent this brain map really
is.
Ultimately it could help understand language
impairments in diseases such as Alzheimer’s.
Mind Blow #82, uploaded in May 2014, featured
SCiO - a handheld spectrometer that detects
the chemical makeup of objects - by scanning
them, analyzing the data in the cloud and
reporting results on a smartphone.
Well, the sensors and development toolkits
are now rolling out and can analyze carbs,
fat and water in dairy, meat and vegetables
and also the contents of pain relieving pills.
The prospects for mobile spectrometer technology
include not only eventually building this
into a smartphone itself - but using it to
detect counterfeit products, compare generic
and name brand products and also the purity
and differences in drugs.
Finally, Eeulume, a company in Norway is developing
a swimming snake robot for subsea maintenance
and inspection.
I’m gonna leave you with the champion of
real robot battle and as always - thanks for
watching.
We're all set for auto control.
Roger, Firebird 2.
Move to electronic control strip in center
lane.
You're now under automatic control.
Hands off steering.
Ah, this is the life.
Safe, cool, comfortable.
Mind if I smoke a cigar?
Oh, not with this wonderful air conditioning.
Hey, you want some ice cream or a cool drink?
Orange juice, please.
Me too!
I'm gonna go for the ice cream.
There's automatic sleep control in every bed
and our predigested food is cooked by infrared.